three weeks into the travel quarantine
and the summer getaway may be back on
the government say they're likely to
discuss airbridges with France Spain and
Greece in the coming days meaning people
returning from those countries won't
have to isolate for two weeks it's good
news for airlines and for those
desperately hoping to make it abroad
very good news guys very welcome news
because we were thought we're getting
married in New Yorker and then we
thought we were getting married just
going to do something the UK and now
would be able to go back to absolute
fantastic we do have flights booked
hotels booked everything we'd all be
cheapest both than once already so it's
been quite a stressful time for us so
hoping this time it will be able to go
ahead we get a bridge mr. Hancock the
men in charge of the country's health
and wealth are you going to get
airbridges sir
we're amongst those discussing the
prospect of airbridges with the Prime
Minister yesterday the balance between
their departments is the most fragile of
all scientists we'll be watching to see
if opening our borders will mean opening
ourselves to a second wave many
conservative backbenchers will be
pleased that Downing Street appear to be
taking decisive action on air bridges
but the next question will be why some
countries aren't on the list countries
will be classified as red amber and
green based on how many co vid cases
they have and foreign office advise
against non-essential travel will also
be lifted from many countries it's good
that they are finally moving in the
right direction as far as we're
concerned but it would have been nice to
add a bit of clarity but earlier because
of the fact that companies had to plan
ahead you can't simply like turning on a
tap you have to make sure planes in the
right place that the staff who've being
put on furlough abroad back the
destinations themselves will need to
know we're on that list the only
beginning ready to accept what will be a
loss of British already makes anyone
flying into the country will still have
to give their contact details but as
Bournemouth buckled under the heat this
week those struggling to make the most
of the great British summer may now be
able to seek sunshine further afield a
leaf will skew Sky News